good afternoon everyone
as you know i'll be holding a press
conference uh
later today
when i look forward to taking your
questions but right now
i'm not going to take any questions i'm
going to head back down to the
to the meeting downstairs but i will be
able to take your questions later today
right now i'm here with the european
commission president vanderline who has
been a great partner
because the united states and the
european union have reached a major
breakthrough
that will address the existential threat
of climate change while also protecting
american jobs in american industry
together the united states the european
union
are ushering in a new era of
transatlantic cooperation that's going
to benefit all of our people both now
and i believe in the years to come
it's a testament to the power
of our strong partnership
and to what the united states can
accomplish by working together with our
friends
here's what this deal does
it immediately removes tariffs on
european union on the european union on
a range of u.s products and lowers cost
to american consumers
it ensures strong and competitive u.s
steel industry for decades to come and
creates good-paying
union jobs
at home
and
and
demonstrates how by harnessing our
diplomatic and economic power
we can reject the false idea that we
can't grow our economy and support
american workers while tackling the
climate crisis
we can do all three of those things
we can and we must do both the american
workers are essential part
of the solution to the climate crisis
and i would argue
i've said before
or so that when i think climate i think
jobs
i think you're good paying jobs around
the world
you know i think it's possible for us to
do both as i said and the workers are
essential part of the solution
building on our close partnership on our
shared values the united states and the
european union
have committed to negotiate a
carbon-based arrangement on steel and
aluminum trade this these uh
arrangements will one lift up u.s
aluminum and steel which is among the
greatest steel in the world that's
somewhat prejudiced on my behalf
incentivize emission reductions in one
of the most carbon intense sectors of
the global economy
restrict access to our markets for dirty
steel from countries like china
encounter countries that dump steel in
our markets
hammering our workers and harming them
badly along with the industry and our
environment
today
is a testament to the power of american
diplomacy and strong partnerships to
deliver tangible benefits for american
workers and the middle class families in
america
i thank gina raimondo
and about our secretary
and ambassador catherine ty
for their leadership to get this done
but they had a really first-rate person
to work with to get it done
and uh
i want to thank the european commission
president
vanderline for her her her team and her
partnership she's been straightforward
from the very beginning as we work to
come up with a creative solution that
benefits all of our people
over the past nine months the united
states and the european union have come
together to take on major global
challenges by looking to all that unites
us and the shared interest we have both
in europe and the united states
we've resolved the 17-year boeing airbus
dispute and we have close partners to
the to address cover 19 and combat
climate change
as we move forward we're going to
continue together to update the rules of
the road and the 21st century economy
and prove to the world that democracies
democracies are taking on hard problems
delivering sound solutions the european
union united states
will continue to be the closest of
friends and partners as we work together
to solve 21st century challenges so i
thank you again president vanderline and
now i turn the podium over to you thank
you
thanks a lot i think i'm over there
thank you very much mr president dear
joe
thank you very much um and i'm also very
pleased to announce that
mr president you and i we have today
agreed to suspend the tariffs on steel
and aluminium and to start the work on
the new global
sustainable steel arrangement
and this marks a milestone in the
renewed eu us partnership
and it is our global first in our
efforts to achieve the decarbonization
of the global steel production and trade
it is a big step forward in fighting
climate change
the arrangement is of course open to all
like-minded partners
steel manufacturing is one of the
highest carbon emission sources globally
and for steel consumption and trade to
be sustainable
we must address the carbon intensity of
the industry
we must also address
problems of over capacity
and this is what the global sustainable
steel arrangement is all about
we will work together with the united
states to ensure the long-term viability
of our industry and
to encourage the production and trade of
low-carbon steel
this new global initiative will add a
new powerful tool
in our quest for sustainability
it will be a major step forward in
achieving climate neutrality
and it will ensure a level playing field
for our industries
it is yet another key initiative for our
renewed forward-looking transatlantic
agenda with the united states
since the beginning of the year as you
said mr president dear joe we have
restored trust and communication
we put to rest our disputes on aircraft
subsidies
we set up our trade and technology
council
we created a vaccine partnership
we reached an agreement on global
minimum tax
and now we have found a solution on eu-s
steel and aluminium trade
i thank you mr president dear joe for
your announcement that the united states
will remove remove u.s tariffs on eu
steel and aluminium
up to previous trade levels
this will alleviate a major part of the
existing trade irritants
it will allow trade transatlantic trade
and steel and aluminium between us
to come back to the levels recorded
before these tariffs were put in place
and following this u.s decision i am
pleased to announce that the commission
will also propose to suspend the tariffs
that we had introduced
i'm also pleased to join president biden
in announcing the pausing of our dispute
on this issue
in the world trade organization
and as you did
mr president diego
i would like to thank secretary of
commerce gina raimondo u.s trade
representative ambassador catherine thai
and executive vice president valdis
dombrowskis for their and their teams
tireless efforts in the last month
this is a major step forward in our
renewed relationship and many thanks for
that looking forward to working more on
this deal thanks a lot thank you very
much thank you folks
thank you so much thank you
thank you